[Music]
poop games I'd like to consider myself a
bit of a connoisseur of poop games and I
gotta say muddy Heights reaches new
heights
let's play it yes let's start with level
one and let's poop on people press so
the goal of this game is to [ __ ] on
people
heavy metal music ah hit that girl right
in the face oh she's laying on it
disgusting oh it's right in your face
dude my [ __ ] is literally bigger than
your torso oh I can move me my poop oh
[ __ ] I made him [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] get the
musician ya'll god they're running away
from my poop no come back here come back
here I'll chase you down with my [ __ ] Oh
God
let's try need a car this time maybe
cause like an accident or some [ __ ] here
we go
come on oh holy [ __ ] literally Oh got
another one come here lads
hey yeah go smack you right in the face
don't run goddammit why is it right [ __ ]
let's got him got your [ __ ] you thought
you had you run for my [ __ ] well you're
wrong here we go right on the poop
tracker oh I thought a secret let's go
up his [ __ ] let's go back to the
motherland take me in
come on I'm gonna go for the music guy
[Music]
what's the matter with me why does no
one like me is it because I'm a piece of
[ __ ] is that why it's that why
god dammit alright we should go for it
lives explode [ __ ] yes
okay let's explode right in this guy's
face yeah diarrhea
take that [ __ ] Lily I did a proof joke
there we go
line up the car [ __ ] hey guys what's
going on here
come and have a bite of that oh thanks I
appreciate it
oh wow it tastes amazing hey you look
you look good you want to go on a date I
really like your chest maybe you could
squeeze one out for me too Hey
oh is that is that ramen I love ramen
Connect okay damn it why am I so lonely
what do I do wrong
zero out of three toilet papers are my
goals okay I don't see any toilet papers
do you bro see any toilet papers hmm
toilet papers
[Music]
where are the toilet papers oh [ __ ]
hell my poop is filled with corn that's
disgusting and when I jump the bigger
come there has to be a toilet paper here
yes [ __ ] yes oh there it is xxx a fun
one how do I get there I need to upgrade
the higher jumps okay well we know where
one is at least so where is the last
Pope where the Bubblegum gives me higher
jumpin poop excuse me guys all right
here it is but yeah why would it poop
need toilet paper isn't that like my
enemy or some [ __ ] or some [ __ ] get it
that's hysterical there it is there it
is I found it all right how do we get to
it though how the [ __ ] did we get to it
I got a [ __ ] umbrella with me what
the [ __ ] is this
come on me jump jewellary pump engine
poof Mary poopins dammit why did I say
it right away
come on ah so close can we do it
[ __ ] they comes a time in everyone's
Navy where we are fearless we're just a
piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
did i disappoint you
hey baby citizen lately sound is like
like playing with fire judges this video
might make up already
oh my God we're so [ __ ] high right
now we're high in life and we're high on
poop
ah [ __ ] come on come on come on
[Music]
job your piece of [ __ ] literally yes yes
oh yeah
[Music]
shed on that I never been so proud
excuse me I really I really gotta go
take a [ __ ] I'm sorry
one of the name money heights youtube
click the link in the description vote
for ya and there you go and you can win
a sign food from beauty and it's AB
Express yeah oh I hit the box I'm not
sure how I fought it seems like I [ __ ]
from my face which is quiet and
disturbing